benoit levy tout est d'origine pour le
moment rien n'a rien et et refaire non
mais en même temps ça irait junte veut
dire c'est pas un gage partech les biens
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas moi ça me barbe ça me gonfle
sur l'école de maintenant il ya plus
tard le sujet dit ouvertement qu on a
fait des choses ttx jean-michel je veux
mais les cheveux derrière ray vous le
pénis mérite une réduction je serai je
serai cyril vous avez foutu dehors des
et joël serait sentez vous sur les
grilles non je voudrais rien fait vous
le nez neuf ça se verrait repas bien
ouais d'accord
non c'est un beau reportage ouais voilà
on est d'accord c'est pas mal c'était
pas caricatural alors on le retrouve
d'énergies douces et quand ils font pas
de la catho match doit avoir joué c vhc
fois ce que c'était intéressant
franchement il y avait des gens qui
témoignait le bootcamp là c'était super
bien
c'était bien fait